lá muito boa tarde antes de mais o meu
nome é bacana
tenho 22 anos e sou cantautor é uma
palavra um dia eu quero dizer que cantou
as músicas que compõem o escrevo também
toca guitarra e hoje estou aqui com
estava andando xpto cheia de amigos
acho que vai ser bastante bom e queria
agradecer muito ao ter ex o convite para
estar aqui
isso tudo cria também dar os meus
parabéns e agradecer a todos os
voluntários que receberam tão bem e deus
desde que entramos aqui a tentar bilhões
do pac que tem uma ressalva para uma
unidade comum e hoje voltar dois temas
originais e este primeiro ano do caixa
mas maria abaixo da brigada
[Música]
cuja roger já foi seu forte
o forte é a sua em usá corre de cabeça
para o coque fada julgar
é um chão min saia num deus deu r está
[Música]
não dá para saltar
só fala do porto e vou à vista
[Música]
qual quê
e é um
here
[Música]
o teu
sites phishing
av
ganhou certa vez a sua
chuta com a força de um trovão é julia
shellman
[Música]
a tga
é
epá
[Música]
sá
as vinhas acho que a vinha
[Música]
que o pa disse vai lá empurra
gosto de dançar
cel
e
[Música]
o zoom gancho
muito obrigado que aproveitará para
apresentar esta banda xpto el kadri
poderão ver né
a minha direita a opção de uma falha na
guitarra e voz joão no cânon e no baixo
e voz pedro castro
eu gosto muito de contar histórias ea
maior parte das minhas músicas são são
histórias que de pessoas que marcaram 16
que marcaram e a próxima especial chamas
freguesia ninguém e fala das vindimas e
surgiu nenhuma vez em que estava no do
destino portugal e estava ver toda
aquela dinâmica das vindimas e e pois é
as idas à igreja e e tudo isso e
compositor da música que permite goste e
agradeço mais uma vez que o convite para
estar aqui pra ela
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de arroz assim que o jem domingues sim o
quadro superior vão
o mauá que investiga corrupção
ele confesse que esperam para lançar
sonhar acordado
mas pelos vistos o povo não está educado
está na hora
k eu espero na frente
[Música]
o seu suspiro já corta a estação os
ossinhos marina presta atenção e nem o
santo duro
dois dedos da conversa mais velho
[Música]
e até os ventos mudaram a direção e os
on peru ave josé não
uma já está pronta nesta gento não
alterarem gillan
[Música]
já o sim
sim o resumo pelo que ele vai que está
na terra não meu deus o que ela tem
ia cuidar é jacob por matar
mas se eu pudesse ter a vila jornada de
um papel
ficar pra mim elas às vezes acho que me
deixa estes campos por abençoar o meu
suspiro anha siga as minhas lágrimas mas
ganhou pelo chão
não é nada que o sol está uma advogada
usou
só me resta esperar pelo coral e wilson
pedro nos quer a
[Música]
dos que os filhos destas sobras mas acho
que elas oe
[Música]
haja esperança que a violência
aja
usa de vir a gente espera
se a haja esperança que a mulher i
[Música]
obrigada
convido os casos tenham estado no plano
mais na minha página do facebook ou
procurar no estranho é só procurar
helena que ela é obrigada mais uma vez
[Aplausos]
[Música]